let's go to the audience why because
without the audience i'm just a guy with
a mic talking to a wall
and let's first go to trent from
wisconsin via discord
davidpakman.com
discord is the place to talk to me join
the discussion trent from wisconsin
what's going on
uh hey there david happy
uh wednesday to you uh recently here in
my home state of wisconsin uh paul ryan
just yesterday came out
and
uh boldly said to the gop of wisconsin
that yes
biden won the election
it was not rigged whatsoever right and
obviously it's been quite some time
since paul ryan has had really
a strong foothold on the gop itself but
he does have a very large presence here
in the state of wisconsin so my question
to you is
do you see more republicans like
paul ryan type
coming out and really uh taking a stand
against more local
governments like wisconsin who are
pushing a lot more election lies
including the
most recent bill that passed uh costing
over six hundred thousand dollars of
taxpayer money to go towards an election
investigation to be totally honest with
you the reason i think paul ryan is just
coming out and directly saying guys
trump lost and biden won
is because he's not looking to get more
involved because i think if he were
looking to get more involved he would
have to tread a little more carefully
because at last check more than half of
the republican party still seems to
believe that donald trump actually won
the election so
i think that the question people have
been asking is
when is a republican like paul ryan who
tells the truth about the election
going to run on the basis of telling the
truth i think the reason he's telling
the truth is he's not planning to run
because i don't know that there's really
an appetite in the republican party
right now for a guy who is going to tell
it like it is they want to keep being
told what matt gates says and what green
says by and large so no i i mean i i
think that um the the most likely thing
is paul ryan is free to say what he
wants because he's not particularly
interested in getting back in politics
yeah um definitely can agree with that
on just about every point there uh i
guess the big thing is does he really
have an influence of any kind even from
a local politics level yeah i think in
wisconsin
he's still a guy that the reasonable
republicans listen to the only question
is how many of the republicans in
wisconsin are reasonable and i just
don't know enough about what's going on
there to say for sure
right right well with a guy like robin
vos running our state legislature i can
easily tell you that there isn't a lot
of uh room for reasoning when it comes
to the wisconsin gop it's really
something interesting and frustrating
just because of the fact that wisconsin
in political history has
a lot of uh really great history when it
comes to both uh
just left-leaning politics and now we
see the extremes of the right-leaning
politics ever since scott walker had
taken over as governor years ago
listen i think that the trigger point
for it becoming more reasonable in the
wisconsin gop and others would be
if the mega trumpus nuttery loses in 22
i think they'll reconsider for 24.
awesome thank you all right thank you
for the call very much appreciate it
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 5 star reviews
and best of all if you don't love it
you'll get 100
of your money back because they stand
behind their product you've got nothing
to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off and free shipping
when you go to four sigmatic dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video